you were already on the right track are
you kidding
hey guys it's Katie and this is another
episode of Wasson translation as you
know we take a recipe we put it into
Google translate it goes from English to
Lithuanian to imara and many many many
more and finally back to English to give
us a hilariously translated recipe today
we have a super special episode because
we have Jasmine facing off against our
hilarious friend Tucker to see who can
make the recipe closest to the original
Tucker loves games he loves puzzles but
he is a novice chef Jasmine may have the
upper hand having so many of these under
her belt but you never know what happens
on awesome translation all right let the
battle begin hey Minnie are you ready
I can't wait I was born almost ready
three two one all kinds of hot bread
something tells me there's going to be
bread involved and maybe it'll even be
hot I'm wearing the wrong shirt today I
should have worn I like to butter my
buns today what are you wearing today
I'm wearing fruit juice Mama we got new
merch everyone if you want some Lost in
Translation merch which was suggested by
y'all make sure to check out the link in
the description below or right here
shopbuzzfeed.com I am very new to this
yes uh but cooking in general as well I
think Tucker probably hates that it's
all kinds of hot bread because it
doesn't give him any context all kinds
of hot bread I don't know you will be
getting two Clues how many did Jasmine
get one oh baby let's go I got a leg up
already good luck Tucker step number one
March 9 large seeds in the Super Bowl
nine large seeds seeds seeds Super Bowl
I'm gonna use a big old bowl for this
Lord Knows Why the word March is there
but nine large seeds tells me I'm gonna
need nine of something March nine large
eggs
crack nine large eggs
like maybe an egg an egg is a seed is it
okay I'm so indecisive just as a human
so I think that this is both the best
and worst possible show for me I think
nine eggs in this bowl and we're going
for it sure why not wow we're crushing
it aren't we I think it's
so now I'm gonna March nine large seeds
into my Super Bowl we have our large
nine large seeds in the Super Bowl and I
think March would be
whip it up so that's what I'm gonna do
directions number two add a pinch of
salt and mix until the pepper whites and
onions are combined and no pepper whites
remain
absolutely add a pinch of pinch of salt
I could do that salt I think is salt
okay a pinch of salt I mean in my
personal language that would mean just
add salt the pepper whites are the
whites of the egg and the onions are the
yolk of the egg mix that egg within an
inch of its life is what I'm hearing
okay here we go a pinch of salt and
we're mixing it until those pepper
whites and onions are combined pinch of
salt mix until the pepper whites and
onions are combined I think that means
whisk until smooth and no streaks of egg
whites are seen But do I add pepper
pepper salt and pepper when you're
making eggs you add salt and pepper ooh
everyone calm down everyone calm down
pepper whites white pepper
okay here we go we're adding some pepper
as well and you know what the word onion
has to be there for a reason so you
don't think any onions or pepper need to
go into it well I just feel like if
onions were meant to be in here it would
have told me the amount pepper whites
and onions I'm thinking like an onion
powder couldn't be couldn't be horrible
garlic powder maybe onion powder is
garlic powder a little garlic powder
look at that confidence did you see me
pick up the garlic powder and put it
right in there we're gonna stir until no
pepper whites remain all right this
looks pretty good step number three on a
separate plate I haven't even used a
plate yet it makes one and a half
teaspoon bottle with half cup water let
it melt I want to let you know that you
only get one clue
I thought those two we are not part of
it
I demand Justice in the comments Justice
mixing makes me think Bowl even though
it says plate I'm going bold we're
putting water in fantastic is there a
water source as well oh yes the sink
which we knew so I'm just going to start
with what I know right up top one half
cup of water here we go okay so that's
one half cup water bottle container
container
um
liquid liquid oil oil water but already
have water so not water water bottle
baby bottle milk or maybe bottle is this
is a bottle right here how's Tucker
doing on this stuff stop no I have to
use a hint up top I'm going to use a
hint and I'm feeling so confident about
that I'm gonna use a hint may I take a
hint from Kelly okay how is the hints
going to be presented to me rhymes
[Music]
this ingredient shares its name with a
drink and you can also use it to clean
your sink whoa bleach
I'm kidding
what do you clean your sink with
cornstarch I wouldn't drink that baking
powder baking
soda soda I drink soda and baking soda
you use when you bake things
right so we have the half cup of water
we're mixing in one and a half teaspoon
in there bottle shots shots shots shots
bottles
bottles soda bottle bottle bottle cap
baking soda I think bottle is baking
soda how would I have ever gotten there
without that hint wow word association
really does come in clutch I would have
never gotten it if I didn't do that
I think let it melt could be just mix it
together if I just had the basic
knowledge of cooking I would be like oh
when you use baking soda you blah blah
but it's like I don't even have that so
I feel like I'm at an unfair Advantage
I'm doing one and a half teaspoon of
baking soda and a half cup of water and
now I let it melt okay so step four beat
the beaten box and remove bubbles with
the tell me beat the beaten box beat the
eggs more maybe I use
this and remove bubbles with a tell me
huh
what to tell me I'm just gonna make sure
that this doesn't have any bubbles
and we're that has more bubbles than
I've ever seen before this is the only
thing I've made so far with bubbles and
I think I need to remove the bubbles by
straining it so that is what I'm gonna
do a tummy is obviously a whisk if you
know anything about cooking you'd know
that I'm over this indecision we're
going for it we're putting that in there
we're beating the beaten box and
removing the bubbles let's see seems
like the more I beat it the more bubbles
happen I don't think I've actually ever
had a recipe to tell me to like to
remove the the bubbles from the egg do
you think Tucker got this for some
reason I feel like Tucker's really
nailing it okay we're removing the
bubbles it seems like the more I oh boy
we're getting a little dirty over here
step number five the refined sieve
strain the potatoes into a bowl
when they are alone something has not
gone right okay we're gonna strain using
the strainer no we have potatoes down
there oh Lord what are you doing over
here oh combine this and make it bubble
I think I'm confident about the eggs I'm
just going to strain the potatoes into a
bowl I think I already did that when
they're alone set to the side is Jasmine
going like so much faster than me am I
being annoying right now when they are
alone these potatoes are alone right now
I'm Gonna Save this little potato water
just in case you don't want to get rid
of your potato water too soon step six
insert the parchment paper into the
eight inch panel
that I mean step six is a game changer
parchment paper is either parchment
paper wax paper or aluminum foil
that is so chef's kiss easy parchment
paper got it eight inch panel It's gotta
be just a pan panel
does that refer to a cake tin a square
tin eight inch panel do we want to make
something circular or do we want to make
something square like this I'd be able
to see the side and see the layers I
think we're just gonna go with that this
I'm like you can't put that in an oven
right it would melt I'm gonna go with
this red square one insert the parchment
paper there is parchment paper so that's
the parchment paper right there should I
cut it so it looks a little nicer okay I
will cut this and insert my parchment
paper so you're feeling really confident
about this oh no no no no no no no so we
put the parchment paper down in there
eight inch panel parchment paper let's
go this is good step number seven we're
moving on to step seven pour the mixture
into the prepared Bowl then cover with
glue make a small hole with a toothpick
it has two holes what has happened was I
supposed to combine these
that we will do okay pour the mixture
into the prepared bowls what is
happening over here which one is the
mixture I think I was supposed to
combine these so what I'm gonna do is
combine them I think the glue is a clear
food wrap and the toothpick we just do a
little two stabs at the top just to let
it breathe we're not trying to suffocate
any potatoes here I will now pour the
mixture into the prepared Bowl I feel
like these two have to be combined at
one point or do I want to save the
potatoes for later and who the hell
knows what we're doing with that okay
then cover with glue I think it's either
more parchment or Saran we're gonna be
bacon or something we're putting that in
there I'm just going to cover it without
the potatoes yet where the potatoes are
off to the side okay this is the
prepared mixture in the eight inch Bowl
my glue is Saran Wrap part of the
challenge is just getting this off of
here okay there we go and we're poking
it with a couple toothpicks
all right yeah baby I'm gonna make two
holes with the toothpick okay we're
moving on step number eight fill a large
pot 1 3 full with water and put the
steamer on High Ground I think this
means to fill a large pot
third of the way with water
add a steamer over high heat couldn't be
more clear I feel pretty okay let's just
examine our heating surfaces right now
look a steamer I mean I guess it is a
large
pot a third with water this thing is
quite the contraption
up what that's a pot that's a pot if
I've ever seen one we're going to the
sink and put the steamer on High Ground
steamer what am I doing
this is a steamer I have filled my large
pot a third of the way with water the
steamer is on high ground which I did
over high heat and it is now boiling I'm
gonna bring this to a boil and then what
I'm putting inside only God knows so
let's move on to the next step step nine
we take the bread and eat it cook for 10
minutes until tender I don't understand
now starting to think that I should have
combined the potatoes with this because
like you want to cook the potatoes and
the Egg am I steaming some bread which
one is the bread my steaming that like
what do I put this inside for 10 minutes
and steam it I think I need a hint do
you want to use your one hand here
hint uh Katie and I want you to yeah
you were already on the right track
are you kidding
someone sings on the show that water
that water
I guess I was on the right track I'm
gonna be adding my eight inch panel to
my steamer here I have a feeling Tucker
honestly won't even need his okay I
think that I need a hint and I'd love it
from memo here we go here we go
[Music]
I'm thinking we gotta put the potatoes
inside because we have to cook both the
eggs and the potatoes
she went
she like started to nod or shake head
and then turned it into a full circle
just so I had no idea what she meant at
this point in time I no longer care when
who how they're cooked I just want to
make sure this thing is cooked okay so
we're adding the potatoes in at the end
of the day we just want to make this
edible okay so we're putting that in
there okay 10 minutes on the clock
it's been 10 minutes it looks good so
this has been cooking a little longer
than 10 minutes begs the question did it
take longer because I wasn't supposed to
add the potatoes oh we did it okay I
think I'm on the right path I think
Jasmine's looks identical to this and I
think the final result looks incredibly
similar to this
number 10. it will be very cold then
shape into one-inch balls remove and
chill so I think it will be very cold
means take it out and let it cool maybe
that just means like pop it in the
fridge or freezer because it's got to
cool down if I'm losing my mind Tucker's
probably losing his mind too so we're
gonna put it in a freezer
I think I'm gonna put this in the fridge
first and then we'll shape them into one
inch balls okay this is looking mighty
cold it is now very cold let's move on
to the second part of Step 10 shape into
one inch balls one inch balls oh what is
this a melon baller we're just gonna
scoop and plate scoop and plate that can
possibly be the price so I'm gonna cut
these into one inch cubes I mean we
gotta take it out of there I'm gonna
flip this yep
I'm not a fan of the color it's gray
from oxidization I suppose what does one
inch balls mean oh my gosh we're just
gonna cut and we're cutting it like a
pie so we're gonna move on to the next
step one inch balls I say no to that
step 11. Peter one of sesame oil over
high heat add the chicken yolk and cook
until browned on both sides five minutes
total and to think that I was doing so
well oh okay so I think I'm gonna be
heating up some oil over high heat we're
bringing back the pan I think my chicken
yolk is my egg but if it's over high
heat it can't be sesame oil because
that's usually a finishing oil so not
sesame oil both sides makes me feel
better because I didn't ball it balls
have no sides science you think Tucker's
putting this together probably Tucker so
smart a sphere doesn't have more than
one side so what's both sides mean all I
know is that we have to add one sesame
oil I'll go with olive oil let me Heat
this up now I'm going to add in my
chicken yolks and I am going to Brown
them on both sides about five minutes so
we are going to slide this in there
that's not moving the way I thought it
would we're just gonna put in these both
sides means that I have to somehow flip
this which will be fun while this is
cooking I'm going to move on to the next
step step 12 meanwhile combine in a bowl
small bowl half teaspoon paprika half
teaspoon white sesame seeds four
teaspoon garlic powder 1 4 teaspoon
ground cumin quarter teaspoon dried
garlic quarter teaspoon red pepper
quarter teaspoon smoked paprika and 1 4
teaspoon South bow
small bowl in a small bowl we have so
many ingredients here that we're working
with and all of them are to me English
words that make sense wait let me just
check on these I don't want it to
definitely time to flip so I'm coming
back to that huge the color is getting
better it's bubbling in a way I don't
like it smells good you know what I
don't care how you think this looks this
is about to taste good with all the
seasonings half teaspoon paprika I do
think paprika is paprika half teaspoon
of paprika half teaspoon white sesame
seeds which are here let's go with white
sesame seed one half teaspoon white
Sesame white Sesame so we're gonna do
half teaspoon of white Sesame next we
have quarter teaspoon garlic powder I'm
gonna do garlic powder 1 4 garlic powder
1 4 teaspoon garlic powder quarter
teaspoon ground cumin I do think it's
cumin ground cumin I don't think I know
what cumin is really quarter teaspoon
dried garlic I think that's minced onion
garlic powder wait I just did that we'll
come back uh quarter teaspoon spoon red
pepper is quarter teaspoon Cayenne not
like red pepper flavor no red pepper is
just red pepper flakes so we're just
gonna do a little teaspoon smoked
paprika but I already put in paprika I'm
gonna go with another quarter teaspoon
of paprika
a teaspoon of smoked paprika put Paprika
in already and then you put
we didn't catch that did we a quarter
teaspoon of Saco which I think is salt
salco salco salco salco
when you say it really fast the thing is
I lost my confidence a while ago so now
I'm just kind of rolling with it step
13. add the onion mix mix and cook for
another minute this is an onion mix did
we have any form of onion in there dang
onion mix mix I feel like I have to coat
it all first and throw it back in there
so I'm gonna take my eggs adding in my
onion mix mix giving it a good toss I'm
gonna add everything back into my pan
and cook for another minute but this is
obviously this has to go inside right so
we're going to sprinkle this on top cook
for another minute so I'm gonna add a
little more oil because I don't want the
bottom to burn right now Tucker's
probably looks amazing or really chaotic
now look at that we're kind of moving
around here last up it is easy
they did say it is easy which I beg to
differ it was pretty hard serve it up
and hope Nana lives there's just another
day it is easy transfer to Plate
final thoughts everything is cooked and
so for that I am blessed
how are you much shorter than you how
about you it was very rough it was rough
maybe for the both of us but I'm excited
to see what you made I'm so excited I
wonder if they look similar or not open
your eyes
oh
that looks incredible that looks
incredible too so clearly we have all
kinds of hot bread here and I am excited
to see the original dish shall we bring
it up let's bring it out open your eyes
oh wow
Jasmine wow I am not gonna lie I'm very
shocked so what is this dish based on a
viral recipe that they found on Tick
Tock we're calling it viral Chinese
steamed eggs I'm dying to try is that
allowed in this absolutely all right
let's okay let's go for it cheers
mmm you are lying to everyone it's not
horrible literally it's eggs and
potatoes it's really good do you want
thank you I would be honored cheers bite
size thank you
it's a seasoned Doug it's good it is
beautiful all right let's give this one
a try Cheers Cheers Cheers
that's really good all right really good
but you're not far off at all I think we
did good thank you so much for watching
thank you again Tucker for being here
thank you so much for having me and if
you want to check out some lost and
translation merch check out
shopbuzzfeed.com and tune in next week
for more surprises bye should we do a
little Glam shots uh don't get too close
with the Glam shots nothing you need to
try Jasmine's do we need to
Nemo eat it I really like the potatoes
thank you bottle of service bottle
service let me just tell everyone I have
an over 200 day Duolingo streak okay so
I think I know how to translate things
uh
[Music]